if life began on mars it probably began  around the same time that it began on  earth so three and a half four billion  years ago but on earth  so kind of paradoxically it's much  harder to look back in time because  earth's active it's got weather it's got  you know volcanoes plate tectonics all  this stuff so the surface is constantly  being renewed and so it's very very hard  to get samples from earth  of earth as it was three and a half to  four billion years ago whereas on mars  it stopped being geologically active  about three and a half billion years ago  so it's been in deep freeze and so these  river deltas that perseverance is roving  across now  are pristine river deltas from  three and a half billion years ago  they're time capsules so it might be  easier to understand the origin of life  if it began on mars it might be much  easier to do so than it is on our own  planet